hey what's going on still burned it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday May 15 2017 halfway through the
month of May oh Jesus Christ
do you know Bobby Orr scored that
[ __ ] overtime goal on Mother's Day to
win the Stanley Cup back then you know I
think you only had to win eight it was
like [ __ ] 12 teams he had the
original six and the expansion six the
original six really weren't the original
six they were just the six left over
after [ __ ] the stock market crash or
some [ __ ]
maybe the only guys left or after World
War one I can't remember didn't like the
Lusitania sink and then that like half
the players on the [ __ ] Montreal
Maroons were on it I don't know what
does it stomp the [ __ ] schwa me over
here you don't he has been been she's
been recording the sports jeopardy aka
Buffalo Wild Wings jeopardy now it's not
even a sports fan it's not easy but
although I seem like a smart when I'm
watching that show to the point here
goes if they ever do any sort of [ __ ]
you know comedian sports jeopardy thing
or you can give the money to a charity I
love that [ __ ] it's like I'm gonna go on
TV on to a game show one of the hardest
game shows out there jeopardy granted
it's all going to be about sports but
they do a lot of [ __ ] of like you know
you know who's the first free agent to
[ __ ] get into a fight with Al Davis
absolutely I don't [ __ ] know right
name the last three owners of the
Seattle Seahawks like they get they take
it to that level you know what I mean
but I love how you know you need was
like oh you should go on then just you
know give the money to a charity [ __ ]
the charity I do enough benefits as a
comedian I can't go on TV try to win
some money for me you know hit a couple
of categories and they're going you know
I'm going to go on TV and
Bo's how limited my [ __ ] I don't my
world is I don't know I'm gonna go on TV
and make an ass of myself and then give
it to some dirty face kid afterwards I'm
gonna lose and then what some kid who
grew up in a [ __ ] chimney is gonna
sit there crying because I went there
and basically did the Babe Ruth thing a
kid I'll go out there and hit a homerun
for you today
except I'll do it with my mind man I'm
gonna go out there and I'm gonna [ __ ]
lose because they're gonna be like yeah
what brand of baseball glove did goose
Gossage use when he was still on the
[ __ ] Oakland A's Rawlings
oh no sorry the correct answer was a
Wilson douchebag family with the chance
to steal um I actually did you know if I
can remember the category my problem
with those shows is sometimes like I
don't understand the you know they'll
say like Get Carter and it takes like me
for like [ __ ] three in a row to
understand like oh these are everybody's
got the last name Carter I got the
hardest one too or maybe I'm just the
oldest they brought up the [ __ ] the
dude on Michigan then I think went to
the [ __ ] USFL make this [ __ ]
Anthony Carter number one I first
started watching college football he was
the man out there with the Wolverines
all right pom pom pom pom pom Papa that
done the great [ __ ] fight songs of all
time to Michigan Wolverines that that
the Dada
I'm [ __ ] with you I know how it goes
hail to the victors value and I was
singing the notre-dame song oh Jesus is
take my oh Jesus they gon foot two-point
conversion there Jesus what do you got
to say well you know I mean if they make
D make it I mean I love everybody get
out of this [ __ ] locker room you
bared it hippy that's what happened if
Jesus came back Jesus ever went to the
locker room and Knute Rockne was in
there right
well five foot nothing of them can
that [ __ ] average height way back in
the day before they put the horse
tranquilizers in the [ __ ] horse me
that they fed to the horses that they
then fed to the cows right that are then
in my burger maybe that's why I have
such a [ __ ] disposition I eat a lot
of red meat there's so much red meat I
eat I don't consider hamburger red meat
to me red meat as I had a steak I have a
program and it's it's not it's not red
after I'm done cooking it you know
actually it's not even true I like I
like all of it medium rare and what I've
been told by a coli freaks where they
like look you can have a steak
medium-rare that's a lot less of a risk
because that's just one cow you know
you're rolling the dice it's like you
bang one hooker without wearing a glove
Jesus bill right and then hamburger
though it's like you Bank Vietnam I
don't know why pygmy --it Nam some
reason I went to [ __ ] Full Metal
Jacket hey baby you got go FEM Vietnam
it's like you banged a [ __ ] country
of that that's what hamburger is because
it's just a bunch of cows all [ __ ]
mulch together right you have a steak
it's like you just [ __ ] one cow that's
what I'm trying to our steer I should
say what's the stair well that's a bull
without his balls buddy all right take
off its [ __ ] horns um I don't know
what it is anyways and if you have
hamburger that's like you know you know
you're just Freddie Mercury running
around [ __ ] the whole free world
isn't that basically it I mean I'm not
you know I'm not I don't know my way
around the kitchen enough to know if
that analogy worked or not but uh I will
say that I let's just get back to the
original point okay what was he original
point yeah I don't consider hamburger
red meat or was it that I'm not given
some [ __ ] kid who lives in a chimney
I don't know why I chimney you know you
know what seeing broke children is
always sad unless they're white this
just something [ __ ] funny but yet you
know I think it's just a relief as a
white person that the guilt goes awake
you don't know you know anytime you see
somebody from another
race broke you know white people [ __ ]
push them out they put a Walmart down
right they put one of those Derrick's in
there they started sucking all the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of it you know I wonder
if people around the world when they
watch the beginning of the Beverly
Hillbillies start crying
you know when they just see the white
man even the first a laugh like oh my
god it's toothless broke white people
hilarious and even they discover oil and
they get to keep it so they loaded up
the truck and moved to Beverly Hills
that is I wonder if they cry when the
children cry you know nobody gets the
movie I was talking about
I kept references we had problems with
the family baggage
anyways let's apply speaking of the
chills and cry that's white lying
everybody when the children cry was
actually a hit that's how [ __ ] off
the rails music went at one point little
jab jagged cryin guys I was like on the
top ten
I remember watching it I didn't give a
[ __ ] about that song but I was like that
lead guitar instead of all these [ __ ]
guys trying to be Eddie Van Halen I'm
not saying this guy was there trying to
do the [ __ ] that Eddie did that [ __ ]
guy white lion he came the closest you
know out of all the white bands you know
the white lions the [ __ ] who else was
it I was white lion Jews great white
it was Whitesnake it was a day away it
was a little-known all-white funk band
because that's what people used to yell
when they went say I care about how it
goes I don't know anyway speaking of
children cry my condolences to all the
fans of the Washington Capitals and you
know what happens when you hit the
[ __ ] wall for the third time when you
win the Presidents Trophy you know under
two different presidents okay when Obama
brings you two and Donald Trump comes in
with his tie hanging all the way down
his tie would still touch the ground
even if he was wearing skates
he comes walking into your locker room
and he gives you that [ __ ] trophy
yeah you're on your second goddamn
president you've left the ugliest
uniforms in the history of the [ __ ]
game of hockey possibly definitely up
there those blue ones with that gold
[ __ ] eagle you know it just looks
like they put a stamp like them like the
post office had a limited stamp thing
you know then all those weird [ __ ]
smelly people you know people don't
bathe collect stamps you know and I'm
not saying that you know with all this
stuff like what do you identify with a
man or a women you know being a man I
don't I'm a man but I don't identify I
still identify we imagined the [ __ ]
emptiness of it every day waking up
shaven going what the [ __ ] is this I
can't relate to this [ __ ] beard on my
face man you know one of my tits gonna
come in I just I can't imagine that but
whatever there's other people that can't
you know they don't identify with other
human beings
forget about they don't identify with
their own gender there's another group
of people that we all need to care about
and we're a certain color on a certain
day or maybe a ribbon for and these are
people that can identify with other
people they just can't identify with
human beings in general and these people
collect stamps you know they just sit in
their room they're not bothering anybody
taking that big giant [ __ ] book off
that shelf you know blowing the dust off
it because they finally got the
Washington Capitals [ __ ] horrific
Jersey from the mid to early 2000s
whenever they had that it was that awful
period that's why in the NHL they added
too many [ __ ] teams and everybody
changed their uniforms I I should put it
all on the Capitals Washington DC
[ __ ] horrific thank god they went
back to the red white and blue you know
I mean you are there in DC for [ __ ]
sakes you know if anybody should have
the color of the flag it should be you
guys you know the Buffalo Sabres
that [ __ ] IHL horseshit they had you
know whether they put a sheep on the
front even look like a bull anymore it
was terrible [ __ ] terrible props to
them by the way when they finally
admitted that they made a [ __ ]
mysterion
they had that strike that they lost a
whole season of the NHL all right
they added a bunch of [ __ ] teams too
many goddamn teams they had the Atlanta
Thrashers
they had the [ __ ] Florida Marlins
right that's right they played hockey
first before they suck so bad they were
like you know what let's just [ __ ]
play baseball
no the Florida Panthers the Lightning
the Coyotes I think the North Stars
moved down to become the stars at least
they kept the kind of they're there all
right because they kept the same [ __ ]
uniforms then of course they knocked
down that Stadium in Minnesota and they
put up the Mall of America there that's
so sad that you know the place where
Dino Ciccarelli smashed and stick over
that [ __ ] guy's head you can now sit
there standing there eating frozen
yogurt without a care in the world
you know or did it was that a road game
anyways the [ __ ] am I talking about yeah
that's right so then you had all these
new teams in the NHL and then on top of
that all these teams that have been
established all changed their [ __ ]
uniforms so you come back after the
strike and you're just watching like
dude this is the [ __ ] Olympics
actually that's not true cuz I did a
bait started doing that in the 90s
because when the Sabres the Sabres got
[ __ ] in 1999 you know back when you
could even have a [ __ ] shoelace tough
like [ __ ] shoe leather that
mozzarella huh who knows that one
there's another obscure tough like
[ __ ] shoe leather that mozzarella
mozzarella whatever the [ __ ] you said
mozzarella uh who knows that one if
you're religious you might know that
that's a hint the title has something
religious and religious figure in it and
it's not Jesus Christ Superstar that's
the last hint I'm going to give you
um yeah the Sabres got [ __ ] in 1999 was
it Brett Hull was it [ __ ] Danny
Mashburn I don't know [ __ ] it was Joe
Joe Barry Carroll who had their foot in
the [ __ ] crease I can't remember but
the whole year they're calling it until
the biggest goal of the year the one
that decides to Stanley Cup Classic NHL
yeah that new rule that's been [ __ ]
everybody all year round yeah forget it
we've decided to change the rule in
overtime in the clinching game of the
Stanley Cup Playoffs that's how we do it
that's right that's how we do it we take
breaks every twenty minutes and we have
rules and all of a sudden the rules go
away so anyways my condolences to the
city to the District of Columbia Capitol
fans man they [ __ ] did it to you
again you know when you keep showing up
because your real fans and you know it's
going to suck now they dismantle the
entire [ __ ] team hopefully they keep
Ovechkin you guys are out of your
[ __ ] minds if you get rid of him are
they gonna blame it all on him did you
see that picture of his leg
I'll [ __ ] bruised up he looked like
somebody tried to get information out of
him he wouldn't give it up you know
[ __ ] veins sticking out um um I
thought it's crying and they uh Jesus
Christ I feel like a bad dad but he is
in there okay he is handling it don't
worry can you hear that yeah this is the
time of night like she's so like wants
to know everything that's going on that
she does she won't nap enough during the
day and by the way [ __ ] all your
suggestions I don't want to hear a
million suggestions put one of her
shirts and in the bathroom that we've
tried everything okay it's just you know
it's a phase she's going through and I
am done listening to [ __ ] people who
are not wearing lab coats if you're not
a lab coat on and you don't have a
[ __ ] little degree hanging on a wall
behind you just keep you [ __ ] ideas
to yourself okay the level of [ __ ] that
parents talk every [ __ ] one of them
has a goddamn cure for every [ __ ]
thing that happens every one of them
just glided through [ __ ] being a
parent or figured it all out and for
some stupid
reason they didn't cash in on it and
write a book why would you do that when
you can just show up to somebody's house
and vomit all your [ __ ] ideas on them
if any of your people's [ __ ] ideas
work you should put it in a book and go
on the Oprah channel you guys can sit
there holding each other's [ __ ] hands
and she tells you how amazing you are
instead of coming over here boring me
with it
and then I go and try it you know
actually you know what the shirt one
worked the shirt one did work I will say
that I shouldn't have [ __ ] said that
because a relative suggested to me and
it was [ __ ] great that's just the
first thing that popped in my head I was
actually thinking about somebody else
that annoyed the [ __ ] out of me with
something else trying to feed my kids
solid food three months into her life oh
no it's fine it's fine ah god this is
this is the danger of riffing because
you end up [ __ ] on the person you're
not upset with um anyways plumbing ahead
uh where am I oh yeah the condolence
just you know so I would I would
definitely keep Ovechkin you got to
build around the guy build around the
guy again and you know get a coach with
a neck in you knows you know maybe he
can see if something was offsides of not
he could you could throw the flag or
whatever you do to challenge it instead
of sitting there with his spine fused
now somebody made the joke said that
every coach in the NH in the NHL looks
like a Bond villain and it is true I am
I got to go with that you know what I
mean although I would say that Claude
Julien clothes yulian looks like that
that dude in the swamp thing that when
he got turned into a monster became that
little guy running around that's such a
weird [ __ ] movie where I don't even
remember the name of the movie the whole
thing about the movie was it was his
chick and she had these giant [ __ ]
tits and you're just waiting for her to
go into the lake so they'd show a little
side boob now this is the early 80s that
was a big [ __ ] thing when you were
like 12 years old all right so the deal
with the Swamp Thing which is where I
got that thing I had problems with the
family back east
that's where it's from its from the
swampthing I'm obviously [ __ ] with
you
what do I talk about yet the swamp thing
right so how that worked he was he was I
forget what hey the guy was walking near
a swamp you know the usual thing and
then a telephone pole falls into the
[ __ ] swamp he gets electrocuted and
then he becomes the swampthing and he's
as strong as [ __ ] and there's some
[ __ ] bad guy so they figure out how
he became the Swamp Thing so then the
bad guy wants he wants a swamp thing of
him sent army a Swamp Thing so whatever
he can take over all the swamps I don't
I don't remember right so this [ __ ]
little weasel II dude he does the same
thing and when he turns into a monster
he's as little as [ __ ] weaselly
monster so then the bad guy goes welcome
he didn't turn into what you are and it
says well you know when you get
electrocuted in the swamp and you turn
into a Swamp Thing it just enhances your
personality alright so if you're a
[ __ ] stud like me who even though I
look like a swamp thing I can still bang
that big titted [ __ ] over there in the
lake if you're a little weaselly [ __ ]
you just become an ugly weaselly [ __ ]
with like mud and leaves for skin there
you go people I know I can't think of a
better I just blew out your is there I
can't think of a better time to read a
little bit of advertising what do you
say what do you say that what do we got
here
oh wait I got a finish so you know one
thing I could say to DC fans is uh when
you finally [ __ ] win it it makes it
all the sweeter just going through all
of this [ __ ] alright I watched the
Bruins from about 79-80 and I had to
wait till like 2011 so what's that uh
$89.99 2009 I watched them for about 33
years alright and I know you got up shut
up all right
you got all those monuments you can
[ __ ] walk around can't you cheer up
did look at the width of the Wizards
forced a game seven I'll talk about that
a little later after I read a couple of
[ __ ] advertisements here HELOCs
everybody Hilux you're unique oh you're
a special little [ __ ] [ __ ] aren't you
you don't walk like everyone else talk
like everyone else sleep
shoe tread like anyone else let me ask
you this why is your mattress
one-size-fits-all I hate this questions
just because this is that general height
that people are from a little baby all
the way up to like if you make a
mattress that fits somebody about six
foot four you're covering like babies
all the way to like ninety percent of
adults it has to be right I don't know
what do I know about mattresses about as
much as I know about reading out loud
but I'm going to continue because a
truly customized mattress will cost you
five to ten thousand bucks until now go
to helix sleep calm answer a few simple
questions and they'll run a 3d
biomechanical model of your body through
the proprietary algorithms they've
developed with the help of the world's
leading economic biomechanic experts the
results a [ __ ] robot shows up to your
front door who looks exactly like you
with the mattress strapped to his back
it gives you your old forearm [ __ ]
shiver and next thing you know he's
banging your wife from the bed that you
paid for sorry no what really happens is
the most comfortable mattress you've
ever slept on shows up right
your lady lays in it she's like oh my
god this is great right she reaches over
for your [ __ ] meat hammer and next
thing you know you need to buy a new
mattress
he likes customers report a 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality and
for couples they customize each side of
the mattress the beginning of the end of
your marriage is when you have the
custom telling you that's the beginning
end of it that starts with that and then
he goes you know it'd be great if you
tits were a little bit bigger right and
then she starts redoing herself like
Matt Damon in the Liberace movie and
then one day just gets rid of her
or maybe nowadays with Millennials it
probably goes the opposite way the way
these broads are slapping the guys
around in the shows now it's
unbelievable hanging them off of [ __ ]
balconies and stuff your mattress
arrives at your door in about a week and
shipping is 100% free that's why
everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes are
all talking about Hell
sleep that's what they're doing they're
not talking about ties they're not
talking about the next hostile takeover
right they're talking about mattresses
you have a hundred nights to try it out
and if you don't love it they'll pick it
up for free
gross and give you a hundred percent
refund no questions asked
go to helix sleep calm slash burn get
$50 off your order that's HELOCs sleep
calm slash / hey helix sleep calm slash
/ oh here we go me undies but elbow
towboat boo me undies me undies look at
that [ __ ] robot dudududu me undies me
undies his balls of metal don't say that
not he walks up your door slams you in
the face
[ __ ] your wife doesn't care the race
cuz his metal nut son nice and soft and
then he lays down on a helix mattress in
bangs your sister
alright elevate your underwear game to
the next level with me undies you've
perfected your wardrobe but what about
the stuff not everybody gets to see
we're talking about you junk everybody
it's time you braided your pubes oh wait
this is the wrong copy if you've been
settling for store - underwear five
packs I have something that will change
your life for the better
it's me undies what's the first thing
you put on and the last thing you take
off oh it's not your socks oh it's not
your contacts that you [ __ ] drawers
it's your underwear make your most
important piece of clothing the best it
can be with me undies follow-up : what
is me undies ah just seriously soft
feel-good undies delivered right to your
[ __ ] door Reed :
right why I'm going to read all of this
[ __ ] my undies are designed in LA that's
either Los Angeles Louisiana and made
from sustainably sourced micro mowed
alamode a fabric three times softer than
cotton and you know what I believe it
now because I have cotton has instead of
[ __ ] word about it and I've been
saying this feat years me undies softer
than soft luxury undies come in an
ever-changing selection of classic
colors bold
and adventurous patterns adventurous
patterns where the outline you dick on
it so you can tailor your undies to your
own personal style and guess what you
can save time and money each month with
a monthly subscription and if you're not
ready for a subscription that's okay man
you can still save there's no pressure
here man that's because my undies is
offering you 20% off your first pair
just use our special URL me undies
dot-com slash / and get 20% off your
first pair so go ahead revamp your
underwear drawer you deserve it you coke
once again that's my undies dot-com / /
me undies dot-com
/ / how many more are these [ __ ]
things out alright Dollar Shave Club do
Dollar Shave Club is this mod a choice
you'll get a great shave at a great
price
conveniently delivered right to your
door you no longer have to schlep to the
store to buy a cheap disposable razor
that gave you a cheap shave or spend a
fortune on razors with gimmicky shave
tech technology you don't need and when
you use Dollar Shave club's executive
razor with their doctor Kavi shave ah
blade just gently glides giving you a
smooth shave dr. Cobb is shaved water
talk to cavies easy shave but as I
called his transparent for a more
precise shave its transparent invisible
like the flames that burn Ricky Bobby
helps prevent ingrown hairs and fights
razor bumps look at that make the
smarter choice by joining Dollar Shave
Club for a limited time new members can
get their first month of the executive
razor with a tube of that dr. Q but only
5 dollars with Free Shipping
after that razor is just a few bucks a
month that's a 15 dollar value for only
5 bucks there no hidden fees no
commitments cancel anytime you like it's
a one night stand but with the razor you
can only get this offer exclusively at
Dollar Shave Club com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / I don't know if
you guys noticed but I've gotten much
better at reading out loud you know
watch this I'm gonna say it right now I
bet I only make
three mistakes in the next two [ __ ]
reads you want to bet what do you want
to bet huh you want to bet a little
cavies easy shape butter I bet you
[ __ ] a handful of that [ __ ]
all right policy genius all right I
never said how fast or slow I go life
insurance do you have it see that nailed
that first sentence if not what too
expensive or a hassle man if you don't
have life insurance what would happen
financially if something happened to the
primary earner what are you talking to
the wife here God knows the primary
earners the biz the man and that's not a
sexist statement I'm just saying I'm
just I'm just a progressive male and
I've listened to all these women [ __ ]
moaning and complaining that we all make
more money to do the exact same job but
wait a minute how many women are
plumbers and then marry a plumber well
that'd be the worst your own [ __ ]
competitive both going to bed smelling
like [ __ ] [ __ ] and wrenches all right
let's keep going here life insurance is
a good idea to protect the ones around
you but where do you go to get the best
prices or the best policy but the best
service policy genius policy genius has
a very simple user-friendly website to
shop and compare all the top-rated life
insurance companies and give you the
best options while you're there check
out their other insurance offerings like
pet insurance pet insurance for what in
case you [ __ ] fish reverse drums when
it flops out of the [ __ ] tank I don't
know I guess for dogs getting their
[ __ ] teeth clean go to policy
genius.com today and save over 40% off
prices for life insurance when life
insurance errs compete for your business
you save money is that a jump while life
insurers ah there's the first mistake
thought is going to get an eagle on this
[ __ ] hole that's policy genius P o L
IC y g e n I us that's the second
mistake I [ __ ] up on the dot
come please spell it out I just did zero
jargon zero sales pressure [ __ ] amount
of mistakes I still got one more to go
zero hassle life insurance made easy
free quotes I got the yips zero hassle
peace of mind don't wait go to policy
genius.com today alright who Billy Billy
bit of it Oh Billy VD I got one more
here Errol
oh no I don't that was the last one oh
this is this guy giving me [ __ ] about
airline bumping well he [ __ ] went off
on me he [ __ ] put me in his place
when he sat down at his goddamn keyboard
I'll get to this in a minute I will get
to this in a minute I like this guy who
gives me [ __ ] about the airline bumping
you know why because it's very few
people out there that defend the man all
right
anybody can attack the man every once in
a while it takes a [ __ ] [ __ ] I
don't know the internet version of that
Clint Eastwood spaghetti western guy
coming to town with his little [ __ ]
Mike Tyson's colorful Mike Tyson towel
over his [ __ ] head right that's how
broke Mike Tyson was when he was a pony
first started out he was like I want to
dress like Clint Eastwood they said I
will get you his underwear his boots and
we'll get that little [ __ ] that
little shawl he puts over but you know
we can't afford to put any color on it
you know and that's the kind of thing
that leads you to bite somebody's ear
off I'm just saying I'm not trying to
say that what he did was right but I'm
just saying I understand um hey how you
doing up there in Montreal everybody
male all Canada how's things going up
there you enjoying the [ __ ] offseason
God knows you're gonna have enough time
to come and see me in June this is what
I'm loving about the Predators alright
although they seem like they're losing
right now I'm taping the game but I'll
[ __ ] I'll [ __ ] myself over here and I'll
just look it up right now oh look at
that the little Time Trial thing are you
gonna [ __ ] load for me I think the
Ducks were up 5 to 2 or 5 to 3
how [ __ ] weird to these playoffs this
year you know anyways now you know I
always give you guys [ __ ] about pet the
curse of Patrick wah you humiliated that
guy I mean what you
did to him when you watch like like
horror movies you know what I mean when
somebody like you know thinks they're
prom queen then you dump a bunch of
blood on them or they think that they
got to go mission make a wish in a well
and then their mother pushes them to the
bottom of it you know what I mean they
think that you know that that all of
that [ __ ] all of that [ __ ]
right somebody drowns in a [ __ ] Lake
you guys did the hockey version of that
- Patrick wha you know he thought you
guys loved him this it was it was like
Carrie he came out there you know has
one [ __ ] bad game you won't pull him
you leave him in there you [ __ ] do a
mock cheer when this guy who redefined
the position first ballot hall-of-famer
continuing the tradition of winning
[ __ ] Stanley Cups you know and he
wanted to during the real era when there
was like 30 [ __ ] teams 28 teams not
all those cups the Canadiens and Maple
Leafs went back in the day when it
wasn't even estate was like a [ __ ]
shot glass it was him skating around
with the thing looks like a [ __ ]
baton you know before it became that
giant goddamn thing anyways they booed
him out of town so ever since then has
been the curse of Patrick wah and I
think the next [ __ ] part the next
chapter of the curse okay is PK subhan
you know you know what they ran him out
of [ __ ] tier and that guy out of town
now this wasn't your fans I think it was
the organization I also think it it's
because I'm a Bruins fan I just love
giving you guys [ __ ] cuz when I might I
do talk about championships you guys are
going to destroy me so this is this
little [ __ ] little thorn I could put
me underneath you [ __ ] elephant foot
here alright what PK was a [ __ ] great
dude anyway he gave too much money that
Children's Hospital and he started
becoming bigger than the Canadians and
the Canadians could [ __ ] handle it
like when Kobe couldn't handle Shaq and
he said look either he goes or I go
and they said okay Kobe and they sent
Shaq to Miami and then he won a [ __ ]
title there right
then they had to bring Phil Jackson back
and another 50,000 [ __ ] free agents
as they always [ __ ] do you know I I
you know I just give Kobe [ __ ] for the
first the first three rings get the [ __ ]
out of here the last two I'll give you
those you know even with the officiating
in that second time you played the
Celtics hey let's call [ __ ] 38 files
on one team and 17 on the other that's
that makes for a good game seven doesn't
it not saying that we would have won
but it would have been nice to see the
Lakers beat the Celtics eight you're
just saying anyways plowing ahead so now
the Predators are up one to nothing
against the [ __ ] Emilio Estevez is
the sheen's whatever the [ __ ] you call
him down there the mighty the mighty
Shane's the Anaheim Estevez is the
Mighty Ducks I don't like the Ducks
I don't like Ducks don't give a [ __ ] I
just don't like them okay I don't like
the Honda Center okay why you go there
there's no [ __ ] vibe there's no vibe
in an eye it's just a [ __ ] it's just
I don't know what it is it's just a
strange goddamn place Anaheim is [ __ ]
weird this whole [ __ ] LA Aries weird
like people weren't supposed to live
here you know what I mean they weren't
supposed to [ __ ] live here it's a
[ __ ] desert we still water the old
all things weird but at least you know
this does cool [ __ ] to look at you know
except when you go to Anaheim I don't
know what you look at all right and you
go down there there's no [ __ ] vibe
maybe it's better I went to a duck's
game in the late 90s they was still
early right there was still the Mighty
Ducks they still had Donald Duck with
the broken bill in the front isn't what
they had for their logo I don't know so
anyways what if what if what if pique
leads the Nashville Predators to a
Stanley Cup championship this year I'm
just throwing that out there for
everybody up there in st. Catharines
street you know with your cute little
pocket squares that matches the color
your socks you know what the [ __ ] you
going to do then Nashville that banjo
playing [ __ ] washboard down by the
[ __ ] River
you ever been to Nashville I mean half
the structures there still have dirt
floors
it's unfuckable it's it's ridiculous you
know like when they went this day when
they went to Nashville this year and
they were like you know who you voting
for for president they like I'll tell
you one thing I vote for Lincoln he
wants afraid slate
that's how backward Nashville is you
know I know there's all this [ __ ] out
there saying it's this growing city you
know and they're trying to get people to
move that the reason why they're trying
to do this because so many the
structures still have dirt floors okay
now if he can go down there all right
and and and [ __ ] lead them to the
Stanley Cup the Big Boy Stanley Cup not
that little shot glass that you and
money you and [ __ ] Toronto won like
[ __ ] 15 times each you know I'll give
the Canadians their last 10 cups but I I
look at him like die I can't say they're
equal Detroit because Detroit was back
then when it was a shot glass you know
sort of a fancy shot glass um anyways um
I'm just [ __ ] with you III no idea
how the [ __ ] predators were in the
finals the Western Conference Finals
with the Ducks and then the Ottawa
Senators what the [ __ ] is going on with
it when it when is one is the the glass
slipper going to turn back into a
[ __ ] pumpkin I'm telling you if
Ottawa goes any deeper into the playoffs
they're actually going to sell out a
home game missus unbeliev did you see
the first game of the Rangers they had
2000 of the Rangers sorry they had 2000
empty seats that's because they stopped
playing the Bruins you know what I mean
and the Bruins were just close enough to
Ottawa that that shuttle flight wasn't
it wasn't too expensive you know then
they played the Rangers and God knows
Rangers fans all those [ __ ] Manhattan
[ __ ] they got the money to fly up to
Ottawa but then New Yorkers do what why
don't they got a boy's head they got a
slice
why would I travel look over there it's
the Empire State Building oh that's what
New Yorkers are they there they're
[ __ ] they like country people you
don't have to be lonely [ __ ] skanks
in the [ __ ] five boroughs I am in an
extra country mood and I am just
trashing people that I have no right to
trash okay my team is not in the
playoffs
okay my team has not won as many
championships as the [ __ ] Canadiens
my city doesn't have as many skyscrapers
as New York City hey don't [ __ ] with my
shitty you just [ __ ] with the wrong
city I had problem with barely bag
reached if you touch my family I'll
[ __ ] kill you those lines will never
get old in Hollywood you know it's
another [ __ ] hacky thing I'm so sick
of every other [ __ ] show doing the
speed-dating [ __ ] scene how many
times can you do that in one [ __ ]
lunatic after maybe it's it's not that
bad
jesus [ __ ] christ people showing up
with like half an axe in the side of the
head people live with their mother the
person who's actually gay pretending to
be straight the [ __ ] psych I mean
Eddie Murphy did this [ __ ] [ __ ] in
coming to America in 1989 Jesus Christ
why you just have somebody come in and
slip on a banana peel and they get a pie
in their face and then do the dating
thing
hey Pope you're so talented why don't
you come up with something new because
I'm limited all right I never said I
[ __ ] die would reinvent something um
all right unfortunately I have to take a
little bit of break and I'm on a nice
little roll here I'm on a nice little
roll here but I have a guy I got
something I got to take care of which is
why I'm doing this at nine o'clock on a
Sunday you know but why do I need to
tell you guys this is only be a [ __ ]
second of your life all right hang on
hang on a moment
okay I'm back I'm back and I am is
illiterate as ever
all right you want to listen somebody
just [ __ ] tearing me a new one here
so I was talking about [ __ ] United
Airlines and
elta and them just yanking people off of
flights and like what happened to
customer service and all of this type of
you know I felt guilty flying United the
way they just dragged that Chinese dude
off the plane of the two going to China
just assuming he was Chinese Asian you
can give me that right who knows who
knows they wait I'm so [ __ ] hard I
don't know
you know [ __ ] dude [ __ ] it anyways
airline bumping you said he says hey you
uninformed [ __ ] and I'll tell you
nothing makes the reader want to read
more when you just start off with the
insults he said Congress and the
passengers Bill of Rights have led to
more passengers getting bumped due to
more cancellations and do you think he
gives any examples now he just moves on
to his next point also if people showed
up for the flights they booked the
airlines wouldn't be overbooked many
passengers booked multiple flights how
about if you buy so you're just assuming
that the guys that they're yanking off
the flights did those people I don't do
that I buy one [ __ ] ticket and I show
up that's how I do it so you're telling
me that that Chinese dude or that other
[ __ ] person on Delta you're telling
me that those are those people so they
said hey you booked like 20 flights you
only showed up for one get out of that
[ __ ] I said get out of there you're
telling me that's what happened or are
you telling me that because other people
do that because the guilty people did it
that United in Delta is now just going
to grab some random innocent person and
throw them off the [ __ ] flight I
heard the reason why they did it was
because they had another plane that they
had to get a flight crew to and they
just [ __ ] yanked the guy off that has
nothing to do with that other [ __ ] as
far as I know but I hate what am I am
just an uninformed [ __ ] evidently you
who just like me just makes statements
with no [ __ ] evidence behind it all
right plowing ahead he goes how about if
I buy a ticket for a flight and miss it
for whatever reason you lose it
mark is that how you run your shows was
that a point how about if I buy a ticket
for a flight and miss it for whatever
reason , you lose it oh how about if you
I don't have a problem with that
I don't have a [ __ ] problem with that
at all I'm on the same page I hate when
I show up on time for the security line
and somebody else shows up super late
and then they get rewarded and get
breezed through the [ __ ] line like
they're in that team like they're part
of the TSA party they're the pre-checked
people do you're bringing up all this
other [ __ ] that has nothing to do with
[ __ ] just somebody who bought a
ticket and sits on the plane I Drive a
car other people steal cars
should I be yanked out of my [ __ ] car
cuz other people are stealing cars this
makes no sense I might be an uninformed
[ __ ] but you are a pompous arrogant
uninformed [ __ ] I could say that because
I'm in show business and you know we're
all down to earth
alright let me read some more of your
air quote points alright is that I is
that how you run your shows no I don't
run my shows like that you know this is
my fault he's how I run my [ __ ] show
I don't have anybody kicked out ever he
could be the biggest [ __ ] ever I kicked
the first [ __ ] person out in ten
years because he was so [ __ ] drunk
I'm a hell of a guy I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm a great guy when it comes to that
[ __ ] how dare you lump me in with United
Airlines and Delta you you you you
hateful so-and-so alright let me please
finish this point here is that how you
run your shows or if someone buys a
ticket to your show and misses it due to
traffic leaving the house late etc do
you honor their ticket to the next show
I will tell you this I've had plenty of
people [ __ ] reach out to me and I
have hooked plenty of people up with
tickets okay how about that has everyone
reached out to me has ever I've seen
every [ __ ] email no but I hope people
up I've run into [ __ ] people walking
down the street driving by in a car
gonna [ __ ]
duh hey gonna go to a joke I'm like it's
all sold out but I go [ __ ] what's your
name I've done that countless times
today you go sir I don't know what
you're talking about
so the equivalent to that is I [ __ ]
pull up stand outside the gates of the
airport go hey you guys fly into
Minneapolis
yes sir we are Oh could I can I buy a
ticket sorry that it's all sold out Oh
apartment I don't worry about it don't
worry we'll get you on the plane and
then they [ __ ] yank someone they yank
somebody off
I don't know why'd they pick the asian
guy huh
why couldn't they pick some [ __ ]
white dude in the suit you know why you
know why all right leaving the house
late do they okay well that is what the
airlines do if you miss a flight they
put you on another one so [ __ ] off you
non-reading pigment impaired [ __ ] that's
not what they do that's what they do
sometimes other times they yank you up a
plane other times they tell you to go
[ __ ] yourself
other times they say hey you have
200,000 miles you can't use them when
you want to use them and if you don't
use them by next Wednesday we're taking
them all back other times they say hey
we just charge an extra because it's
post 9/11 we lost all this money which
is charging for food but eventually
we'll [ __ ] stop overcharge and we'll
stop charging for this [ __ ] for all the
money that we lost in 9/11 which you
know we're now going to pass on to our
[ __ ] customers so they take the hit
when was [ __ ] 9/11 I know I'm an
uninformed [ __ ] as far as my calculation
we're coming up on the 16th anniversary
this September you're still paying for
Pringles aren't you sir
I'm all for defending the [ __ ] man
when it's when it's 14 I don't know what
you just [ __ ] you just brought up a
bunch of I guess behavior by frequent
flyer people so then evidently I should
get yanked off a plane at some point
because other people over booked and
[ __ ] you know what you're you're the
kind of person that probably likes that
that what they call to trap
- the trick car whatever that [ __ ]
show is you probably like that show you
probably think that that's a good
[ __ ] show right that show I can't
believe that [ __ ] show is on
television for the it's on truTV we
should change the name - [ __ ]
horrific TV they [ __ ] think they
drive down to like the [ __ ] projects
and they leave a car with the door open
keys in it running and then they wait
for someone to [ __ ] steal it and then
they act like they got a bad guy off the
[ __ ] street and I was reading
comments underneath it you know I love
that they going to go out of their
[ __ ] way to go down there and try to
get someone to go to jail why don't you
go down there and try to help somebody
out I saw one guy he actually stole the
[ __ ] car he knew it was the trap car
whatever he's driving with the door open
cuz he knows that they just love a
[ __ ] hit the lock so you can't get
out and he's saying he knows it's a trap
car he's waving to the camera all that
they asked if he knew was a trap car why
did you do it he said I don't know maybe
I just want to get on TV and then he
laughed and everybody's like that guy's
crazy I want to party with that guy that
guy's a dope or anything it was it was
to me it was [ __ ] depressing like
that that's the level of options this
guy as in his [ __ ] life that he would
do something like that somebody else
brought up a great point okay like why
don't they take that car around the
[ __ ] suburbs to the whites
cul-de-sacs why don't they do that never
sir boy kids don't steal cars the [ __ ]
they don't they absolutely do and I'll
tell you there's a point my [ __ ] life
I would have done that I absolutely
would have done that just for this
stupid [ __ ] just to have the story so
I could talk about it loudly around
chicks that I liked because I didn't
know any other way to approach them if
they ever did that in a [ __ ] suburb
and a bunch of white kids started going
to jail over that [ __ ] that [ __ ] would
not only be entrapment it wouldn't be
held up in court and the [ __ ] show
would be shut down all I'm saying okay
you sir you probably like that type of
[ __ ] you probably like that show do you
think that's a good show and hey let's
let's you know rather than giving this
guy an opportunity you know they could
just as easily couldn't truTV have a
[ __ ] show where they go down and they
try to give somebody a [ __ ] job you
know
anyways plowing ahead making your own
baby food a billy burp had my first kid
a couple years ago gratulations a friend
suggested we make our own baby food
because it's easier to get them to
transition to real and healthy foods we
tried it and it was fun
French suggests that we make our own
baby food because it's easier to get
them to transition okay alright we could
hide this another fun guy no lab coat no
degree we couldn't do it 100% of the
time but it was totally worth it my kid
isn't that picky of an eater and I like
to thank think that days of pulverizing
fruits vegetables and oats into tasty
meals oh it's because of that I'm sure
you can afford the good stuff for the
little lady but just thought I'd throw
it out there thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
yet I don't know - I don't know what to
tell you I'll cross that [ __ ] road
when I everybody's always like you know
got all these goddamn suggestions it was
somebody [ __ ] you know everybody
talking about like private schools
versus public schools it's like these
[ __ ] kids they don't get to be kids
anymore
they should be out [ __ ] you know this
whole [ __ ] thing that you know from
day one like you just got to be like
you've seen what it does in these
countries that [ __ ] push their kids
too hard they have like ulcerated
[ __ ] bottles like they've been
working on [ __ ] Wall Street for 60
goddamn years and they're like seven the
level of stress that they put on him
[ __ ] that my kids going to be a goddamn
kid alright I flunked everything [ __ ]
in high school I [ __ ] up everything I
got a rest of it drinking and driving I
was unloading trucks I did all of this
[ __ ] and then one day I just figure out
what the [ __ ] do I what do I want to do
you know I found a passion and I
followed it and I was fine and I'm ever
back in the day they used to [ __ ] oh you
need two years of the language if you
know two years of a [ __ ] language you
can't well it's all [ __ ] bull you
know you should say that the [ __ ]
language teacher [ __ ] everybody [ __ ]
everybody let your kid be a goddamn kid
and [ __ ] all these [ __ ] private
schools within nine zillion dollar
[ __ ] you know oh you bet
in when the kids are just playing with
blocks the early you you get in the
better chance you have for your kid to
continue on in other words start [ __ ]
lying in our pockets now yeah why don't
you just have a wouldn't be cheaper to
just have your kid homeschooled you're
gonna drop all that [ __ ] cash like
he's already going to Yale and then
[ __ ] going to school and then go on
the wheels on the bus go round and round
round and that'll be enough yeah the
credit card didn't work yeah I can't
teach you the rest of the song all right
birthday boat party a bill you
bald-headed eagle Jesus going [ __ ]
old school on that one hey a chiseler
hey ya Sidewinder recently my girlfriend
dumped me over a text message I swear to
God if that existed back in the day I
would I would [ __ ] be lighting phones
up if that wasn't bad enough I got the
text just as I was walking into a movie
with a buddy she told me straight that
she didn't love me anymore I took it
like a man watched the movie went home
and cried like a [ __ ] honest guy
two days later I went to a party on a
boat I spotted my now ex we made eye
contact and she looked away so now I'm
trapped on a boat for four hours you
didn't know that she was going to be
there with a bunch of drunk [ __ ] I
don't want to be around and of course
her I made an attempt to ask her why the
[ __ ] she had the balls to dump me face
to face but she ignored me totally as
she's young and immature I then saw her
walk over to a guy and start kissing him
Jesus Christ I commend you sir for not
throwing yourself in them also overboard
a [ __ ] double murder / suicide bill I
have no [ __ ] idea I didn't punch this
[ __ ] but I decided not to I now wish I
had punched his stupid [ __ ] face and
my question is what should I have done
something [ __ ] now why you punching him
he's doing what he's supposed to be
doing he's supposed to be out there
trying to [ __ ] hook up with women
alright
any bad feelings you have should be
towards her but here's the thing dude
you know in the long run she did you a
favor because she didn't love you okay
and eventually she could have done that
while you had two kids with her and you
actually had to pay her [ __ ] money
she did you a favor all right
yeah don't ever do that that's the
dumbest [ __ ] Evan when people [ __ ]
date somebody and then they get dumped
and then they're [ __ ] dating somebody
else I mean and then you go over and you
confront the other [ __ ] bar they they
did they're outside the circle you know
so um what should you have done you
should just been a [ __ ] gentleman
that's what you should have done you
just be a [ __ ] gentleman just feel
like a you know evidently you know she
doesn't want to be with me anymore I
mean dude I know listen I got dumped I
know how [ __ ] hard this is I'm on
time I actually [ __ ] was talking to
somebody hard on the table this woman
dumped me out of [ __ ] nowhere and I'm
in a bar of course and I'm talking to a
buddy of mine and and the problem was he
got dumped like four years earlier and
he still wasn't over and he [ __ ]
hated women so this is what I'm pouring
my heart out to and I was like you know
I mean I thought everything was going
fine what the [ __ ] and I did all that
[ __ ] and he just goes hey you know I
don't know maybe she wanted to [ __ ]
somebody else and I just said you know
what I said you know what [ __ ] you
I actually flipped I was like [ __ ] you
you think that has nothing to [ __ ] do
with this that is new what that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] you dated four
[ __ ] years ago
he is still not over and I've been
having to [ __ ] carry you off the
field like Kellen Winslow after that
[ __ ] overtime game for laughs out of
every [ __ ] bar for the last four
years you can't sit there he's like dude
I'm so hey go [ __ ] off I just brought up
a bad memory
um actually did I say that that's
probably I said on the way home I think
I said that on the way home I think I
just said [ __ ] you when I walked out of
the bar that's right
that's what happened that's how old I am
I'm so old my memory is the fantasy
my memory is what I should have said I
did say [ __ ] you and I walked down so
god I just [ __ ] walked out one of the
few times I didn't pay for my round of
beers I was just like [ __ ] you walked
out anyway she said hope you well thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself dude you took it
like a man what are you gonna do and you
know keep taking it like a man and keep
going home in private and cry it out of
yet that's what women do
[ __ ] they cry it out of them and then
they can move on the fact that she
dumped you and then of course it was
immediately making out with this guy is
really suspect but you never know at
them you never know that could have just
she could have just picked that guy
because you were there you have no
[ __ ] idea and here's the thing dude
even if she was already banging that
[ __ ] douche while making out with
that douche when she was with you then
that's the tent that's who you were with
so good [ __ ] riddance all right
that's what you had you you thought you
drafted somebody in the first round that
didn't [ __ ] work out and you know
what that guy just picked up her
contract for you you know so now you got
all this cap space alright go cry out of
your [ __ ] heart you know but don't go
around hating women that's what I did
big [ __ ] mistake all that does is
stop you from meeting the [ __ ]
sweetheart because you know who loves an
angry woman hater a [ __ ] psycho chick
alright there you go alright
Russian girlfriend a Billy blue balls
hey man I was waiting I was wondering if
you could give me some advice I'm a 27
year old from New Zealand and current
resident and current oh Jesus and
current currently residing is what you
should have said instead of current
residing here current resident here come
residing here okay I've met and recently
started dating a girl from Russia
we've been officially dating for about
five months now everything is going
great never been happier if she ever
asked you to take a boat ride don't get
on the [ __ ] boat alright
and I'm not talking about because of the
last thing all right this one you show
up there's a couple other shifty guys
there and then your identity gets stolen
and we never see you again
all right she's hot best in bed I've
ever had and I've had a lot haha got a
great personality and someone I could
see going further into the future with
okay well you're writing me so I know
the other shoe is going to drop the only
issue is that her visa is about to run
out in a few months
Oh before she moves back unless we can
she can find a decent job here the only
issue with that is the job market over
here for the type of work she is after
is very small a translator we've been
checking the job sites and whatnot over
the past month with not much luck so
I've put up the idea of maybe heading
over to Russia and try to start a life
over there oh no [ __ ] no but that's a
great way to see if she's with you
because she wants to be with you though
now my qualification can take me
anywhere in the world but I'm still
skeptical on Welsh I just uplift my
whole life and move to a country that
doesn't really speak much English
apparently with my girlfriend that I've
only known for a few months plus not
knowing much Russian yeah plus you don't
know how that country [ __ ] works all
right
you have no idea how that [ __ ]
country works dude you're talking like
you're dealing with the [ __ ] mob hang
on one second all right sorry I just
realized that double-booked myself I had
a [ __ ] fake you so much yeah dude you
have no idea like what's going on over
there like that's a whole different
[ __ ] animal over there that's a whole
different government the level of
influence that the mob has I mean that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] hardcore over there
Russia is no joke what if [ __ ] did you
say you were coming from you've gone
from New Zealand to Russian you give the
gardening
[ __ ] that dude [ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that get her a job interview there see
how beautiful she is and you know that
you know do what you can [ __ ] do dude
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that
repeat [ __ ] that I mean I've been
reading the rest of this [ __ ] that do
not move from [ __ ] New Zealand to
Russia jesus [ __ ] christ do not do
that please don't do that okay I never
beg in the podcast but I'm begging you
right now do not [ __ ] do that
Jesus you're gonna go from the [ __ ]
Garden of Eden to then now you're the
immigrant now she's trying to get you a
[ __ ] job you know what kind of money
you're gonna make over there I got no
[ __ ] idea [ __ ] that all right soccer
coach rips off shirt after ejection hey
Billy dad second that was as original as
Billy bald eagle was uh not alright saw
this video and thought it might interest
you during a recent soccer game an
Argentinean player accidentally knocks a
player out from the other team and ends
up getting ejected from the game as a
result after he gets ejected the coach
freaks out yeah watch the clip start
yelling at the refs then he gets ejected
so when he realizes that he's also
ejected he rips his shirt off only to
reveal he's an older guy too you know I
don't know I can't tell all the guys
somewhere between 40 and 50 rips his
shirt off only to reveal that not only
is this dude [ __ ] shredded but also
his whole back is covered in tattoos
making him look like he spends his free
time going to bare-knuckle brawl and um
by the shipyard thanks for all the
laughs and go [ __ ] yourself yeah I
watched the clip of this this guy looks
like this guy looks like he's done some
time in prison what's amazing is the
rest of his body that you can see he has
no tattoos and then on the back it's
just like I don't know what the
he's got going on but his entire back is
covered and it's all of those you know
uh you know if you touch my family I
will [ __ ] kill you it's those kinds
of tattoos it's not the I was in a frat
I got drunk one night and all right this
is my old girlfriend's name and we
[ __ ] turned into a swan or whatever
the [ __ ] they do this is like hardcore
you know this guy's going to punch you
in the throat it's a great clip I really
appreciate it all right let me make sure
I did everything here
Russian girlfriend do not stay in New
Zealand birthday boat party yep you got
a lot of CAP space good for you making
your own baby food
you know I'll see about that
airline bumping a agree to disagree but
I like the fact that you went out there
and stuck up for the airlines and I
think that said I've read all the things
right oh I didn't talk about the f1 race
[ __ ] did you guys watch it have
a guy no I know after Nia's just
absolutely eviscerated watching racing I
hope if you were going to watch a race
the Spanish Grand Prix was a great one
Lewis Hamilton had the pole Sebastian
Vettel I think was yeah it was in the
second position and then Boris Karloff
level if I can't keep forgetting his
name [ __ ] Lewis Hamilton's driving
mate there his [ __ ] car caught on
fire but the first guy the other guy who
drives for Ferrari whatever [ __ ] his
whatever his name is Ricky Ricardo I
can't remember no Daniel Ricciardo
drives for Force India no he doesn't he
drives for Red Bull why don't I just
[ __ ] go on and look up the goddamn
names because most you guys don't watch
this [ __ ] see Tony you don't know what
you guys know as much as I [ __ ] know
so here's what happened all right
the race starts and what's-his-face
Lewis Hamilton as always gets a bad
[ __ ] start Sebastian Vettel goes
around him Vettel drives the Ferraris
Lewis Hamilton's with Mercedes Vettel is
out in final arming [ __ ] points he
was ahead he was like 15 points ahead of
some [ __ ] and in the old days last year
I live on watching for a year the old
days which is Monaco of last year when I
started watching if you would if you
went to the turn first whoever won got
got through the first turn first in
first place drove in the clean air that
was it you won the [ __ ] race unless
you messed up a pit stop or you your car
[ __ ] the bed so he gets out in front and
then his buddy there the other Ferrari
guy gets knocked out of the race okay
and they [ __ ] they cut to this kid in
the stands where this Ferrari thing
where are the drivers why is it so
difficult drivers here we go here we go
I should had this all ready to go I'm
sorry I'm like slowing this the [ __ ]
down the reckonin guy gets knocked right
out of the race and this little [ __ ]
kid they cut to him he's wearing all
Ferrari gear and he's just crying his
eyes out and they're sitting there going
well like Vettel still in first place
well he must have been a big raking and
fan of the [ __ ] you say his name and
they showed him twice bawling his eyes
out I could leave a kid this little was
that into racing I thought it was really
cool and later on the driver got knocked
out of the race Ferrari they actually
they brought the kid in and he took a
picture with them and everything so
ended up being a good deal although he
probably cried again when Lewis Hamilton
went around a but um anyways it was a
great race from front to back these new
[ __ ] tires I guess I have no idea why
they got more grip there's more passing
Lewis Hamilton passed Sebastian Vettel I
think on like lap lanes like 20 laps to
go which never happened last year the
second-place guy just could never get
around the first place guy once he was
out there I don't know it was a great
race and then Lewis Hamilton for some
reason was like [ __ ] out of breath
when he was talking because I've seen
because they got the fatter tires they
can pull more G's and like just see
physically what the [ __ ] they were going
through and Lewis Hamilton didn't have
any drinks on board I didn't know they
had drinks on board I never even dawned
on me but he didn't want to add any more
weight to his car so he lost like four
and a half pounds so there you go you
know that actually you know this people
here in Hollywood that have enough money
now that the day before they have to go
to like a red-carpet event they're gonna
[ __ ] you know drive around in a
[ __ ] race car for three hours so they
can drop that final [ __ ]
four-and-a-half pounds I'm telling you
it's going to happen so I believe the
next next races in Monaco um I don't
know I'm enjoying watching it Nia's got
me all self-conscious about talking
about it now I want to blame her then I
wasn't prepared to talk about it
was there anything else on my little
list here fellas you nerds always wanted
to you riff the whole thing pretty much
pretty much but I make like a set list
[ __ ] I want to talk to if I can [ __ ]
find it the hell is it I give up
I [ __ ] give up with this [ __ ] what
did I have on here I don't know what
that is
we'll close this window this is the most
anti climactic ending to a podcast ever
all right
I said predators Lewis Han Hamilton
Sebastian Vettel Daniel Ricciardo first
time he was on a podium this year oh he
had to give a shout-out to Force India
still rocking the fuchsia whatever color
that is um I think that was it oh happy
Mother's Day belated Mother's Day to all
the mothers out there had a great time
we went to brunch yep that's where I am
right now I went to brunch my parents
came out met the granddaughter they were
over the over the moon loving her if she
was so cute and and was just didn't cry
doll the whole meal and then she got in
the car and then that was it she had
friggin had it and was just crying up a
storm and but it was it we ended up
having a great day and I came home and I
was like it was crazy you know I've just
finally entered this part of my life you
know my parents are older I got a little
one I'm at brunch and I have no say in
the matter and you know what it feels
good I had a great time you know we had
all kinds of family had a big crew seven
or eight people and went to this [ __ ]
insane brunch and everybody threw down
and had like 3000 calories each great
conversation great people it's just it
was awesome all kinds of pictures and
that type
and other than the fact I forgot my
[ __ ] wallet because I decided to wear
his suit and I was going to be the Big
Shot picking up the [ __ ] check and I
had to go to my parents so now now you
know in a few days when I take him to
the airport I got to give him the
[ __ ] money back but oh god it was
embarrassing really embarrassing
so anyways that was my Mother's Day go
[ __ ] yourselves
I will check in on you on Thursday and
let's go predators and I don't know I
mean I got a bunch of friends and you
know what in Pittsburgh I'm just rooting
for extra hockey at this point I hope Oh
Series goes seven games
I don't be this little [ __ ] Kunti
gargoyle [ __ ] on the Ducks I don't
want to [ __ ] do that you know why do
I got to bring at the Predators success
and then [ __ ] on Canadiens fans you know
all their pocket squares are all soaking
wet from them blowing the noses and
crying about losing to the Rangers I
don't need to do that not to mention I
have no bragging rights my team that
[ __ ] bounced out you know I'm gonna
try to be I'm afraid to go Cutlass for
the rest of the Stanley Cup Playoffs how
about that
Celtics first The Wiz he's on down ease
on down the road tomorrow my brain says
it could go either way but my heart says
there's no [ __ ] way there's no way
they come in to the garden even though
it's not the garden
it's the fleet's at the garden [ __ ]
slash whatever [ __ ] Gossett junior
whatever other [ __ ] tags they have
for that thing and I just don't see them
doing I feel like you know what it is
the Celtics they got that sound in their
crowd the same way the yank old Yankee
Stadium had it you know knowledgeable
fans with a history of success and that
can push your team to [ __ ] win I
think they're going to do it all by the
way Derek Jeter huh I missed it I was at
brunch I missed it but that's what a
[ __ ] class act man he's such a class
act he can go into New York and wing a
speech and still kill it that's it man
they're artists single numbers see if I
can do it
Billy Martin number
number two Derek Jeter number three Babe
Ruth number four I always [ __ ] this up
that's Gehrig 5 is DiMaggio and six I
looked up today because that's the one I
always forgot but they said it was Joe
Torre but I thought somebody else had
six uh sevens Mickey Mantle number eight
is [ __ ] Yogi Bear in somebody else 9
is Roger Maris 10 is Chris Chambliss 11
is Gary Sheffield I don't know the rest
of them Thurman Munson's 15 who else do
I remember Reggie Jackson the editor is
that was 44 bo Diaz what somebody would
be worth 30 I don't [ __ ] know alright
that's it that's the podcast I will I
will check in on your Thursday and God
bless all the mothers out there we work
with the family back east all right I'm
done